hallo deutsch schule
aussprache training
und
[Musik]
der frosch der frosch
die frösche
die
frösche
der frosch hüpft über die wiese
der frosch hüpft über
die wiese
der frosch fängt eine fliege
das eichhörnchen
das
eichhörnchen
das eichhörnchen ist gerne müsse
das eichhörnchen
ist gerne nüsse
rennt schnell
das eichhörnchen
der
schokoladenkuchen
heute packe ich einen leckeren
dieser schokoladenkuchen schmeckt so gut
dieser
schokoladenkuchen schmeckt so gut
die chilischote
ist scharf wie chili schote ist schaaf
heute koche ich eine suppe mit scharfen
chili schoten
scharfe chili schoten sind gesund
isst du gerne scharfe chilischoten
der schatz
die
schatzkarte die
schatzkarte
der schatz ist auf der schatzkarte
eingezeichnet der schatz ist auf der
schatzkarte
eingezeichnet
die piraten sind auf der suche nach dem
schatz
aber wir deutschlerner haben den schatz
wir haben den wortschatz
china
in china gibt es sehr
köstliches essen
das chinesische essen ist man mit
stäbchen
die
stäbchen die
stäbchen
die schuhe
die hochhackigen schuhe die hochhackigen
schuhe
die hochhackigen schuhe nennt man high
heels die hochhackigen schuhe nennt man
high heels
die turnschuhe die
turnschuhe
die turnschuhe trägt man beim sport
die anzug schuhe
die anzug schuhe trägt man im büro
die
fußballschuhe die
fußballschuhe
die fußball schuhe trägt man beim
fußballspielen die fußball schuhe trägt
man beim
fußballspielen
die
skischuhe die
skischuhe
die skischuhe trägt man beim
skifahren die skischuhe trägt man beim
skifahren
die bücher
in der bibliothek
gibt es viele bücher
ich lese am liebsten
kochbücher
liest du auch gerne bücher
das schloss
die schlösser
die schlösser in
deutschland gibt es viele schöne
schlösser in deutschland gibt es viele
schöne schlösser das berühmteste schloss
in deutschland ist schloss
neuschwanstein
das berühmteste schloss in deutschland
ist schloss neuschwanstein
das licht das licht
in der disco gibt es viele grelle
lichter in der disco gibt es viele
grelle lichter
das licht einer taschenlampe
leuchtet hell
jetzt geht mir ein licht auf
jetzt gebt mir ein licht auf
der chef
der
leitet das unternehmen
der chef leitet das unternehmen
heute habe ich ein gespräch mit meinem
chef
der chef in einem krankenhaus ist der
chefarzt
der chef in der küche ist der küchenchef
der fisch
der fisch schwimmt im ozean der fisch
schwimmt im ozean
der goldfisch
schwimmt im aquarium der goldfisch
schwimmt im aquarium
juhu ich
habe einen fisch gefangen
ich habe einen fisch gefangen
fischers fritze fischt frische fische
die milch die milch
die milch ist in einem tetrapack
ich trinke meinen kaffee immer mit milch
wie trinkst du deinen kaffee
der schrank
der schrank der schrank für die kleider
ist der kleiderschrank
der schrank für die kleider ist der
kleiderschrank
heute nehme ich mir ein schönes sakko
aus dem kleiderschrank
schreiben
ich schreibe mit einem schönen stift
am liebsten
schreibe ich mit einem kugelschreiber
am liebsten schreibe ich mit einem
kugelschreiber
manchmal
benutze ich aber auch einen bleistift
zum schreiben
manchmal
benutze ich aber auch einen bleistift
zum schreiben
schreibst du eigentlich mit
rechts oder mit links
der elch der 11
das geweih
das erste bei
der ich besitzt ein großes
elchgeweih
der elch besitzt ein großes
der kelch der kelch der könig trinkt aus
einem goldenen kelch
der könig trinkt aus einem goldenen
kelch
der könig hat zu viel wein aus einem
kelch getrunken
der könig hat zu viel wein aus seinem
case getrunken
schwarz
alexandra trägt ein schwarzes kleid
die schwarze handtasche passt perfekt
zum schwarzen kleid
der schal
im winter trage ich einen warmen schein
sofia trägt beim skifahren einen
schicken schale
sofia trick beim skifahren einen
die chemie
das chemielabor
der chemiker
der
chemiker die chemikerin die
chemikerin die chemiker
arbeiten in einem chemielabor
die chemiker arbeiten in einem
chemielabor
der chemie lehrer
die
chemielehrerin
die chemielehrerin
und der richtet chemie in der schule
die chemie lehrerin
unterrichtet chemie in der schule
schwimmen
das
schwimmbad
schwimmbad der
schwimmer schwimmt in einem
schwimmbad der schwimmer schwimmt in
einem
schwimmbad
schwimmst du auch gerne in einem
news news news
werde mitglied unseres youtube kanals
und unterstütze uns mit einem kleinen
betrag
stufe 1 kostet nur 0 franken 95 im monat
du kannst jedes video eine woche früher
sehen
du bekommst images für den chat
wir korrigieren und beantworten deine
kommentare
stufe 2 kostet 1 franken 95 im monat
alles von stufe 1 ist inklusive
wir posten exklusiven content in der
community
es gibt einen live stream im monat
stufe 3 kostet 5 franken 95 im monat
alles von den stufen 1 und 2 ist
inklusive
du bekommst zugang zu unserer
lernplattform
wir geben dir ein blick hinter unsere
kulissen
und das beste für unsere abonnenten
ändert sich nichts
auch alle nichtmitglieder erhalten
weiterhin jeden sonntag ein neues video
und viele post
klicke auf den button
abonniere den kanal der halle deutsch
schule und aktiviere das kleine
glöckchen
gib uns jetzt einen daumen nach oben
und klicke auf diese playlist für
weitere videos zum deutsch lernen